you it's starting to sense that fandom
or people coming at you you're in Vegas
the ladies what's the deal I mean yeah
it's it's a weird feeling it's a surreal
feeling you know coming out and
especially like I said I've been kind of
this little bubble for a long time so
like coming out and actually being out
in the public it's a lack of you'll
we're willing at times but it's fun so I
mean I love meeting people so it's when
I just chat with people the thing is
like you were such an emotional sincere
guy all season long so in touch with how
you were feeling about everything
looking back anything you would have
done differently did you feel I was too
in my head or what do you think watching
the show back
oh no honestly there's nothing I would
do differently no something I think I
could do differently you know when I was
in that moment that's how I felt you
know throughout the whole thing so no
there's nothing I would do differently
and honestly like I don't have any
what-ifs like looking back on it I don't
have any what I still have to ask myself
which is a good feeling because I can't
imagine having to ask myself are you
over Becca now have you spoken to her at
all since after the final rose
no I mean we haven't spoken we hadn't
spoke that was only first time and last
time we spoke but yeah definitely
already know I'm ready to move on and
close that door it was just funny after
the final Rose was actually not really
seeing her that hoping it actually
seeing them together on that couch you
know cuz that you don't really see them
when they're you know when her film we
don't really see him together so when I
saw them together on that couch I'm
happy and everything they were I was
like okay yeah that's where I'm at right
now have you dated anyone since oh no
I'm not really you know I'm 18 but yeah
there was a rumor about another
bachelorette gal Kristina Schulman yeah
no well I also want to ask about you
being the bachelor because so many
people wanted it so badly and you post
it on Instagram saying that you wouldn't
change for the show what did that mean
honestly if so it was more for so a lot
of my fans are upset that I wasn't
campaigning it was not the campaigning
doing interviews and that kind of thing
and that just wasn't me that's not who I
am so it was actually more for my fans
estelle them like you know you didn't
you wanted to be a certain person when I
was the bachelor I wasn't gonna change
that to become the bachelor
that's kind of what I was saying so you
know I wasn't out there campaigning I
was you know I was just I just be myself
and you know laying low if you will and
then if it happened it have a lot of the
other guys did you know I'm the you know
Colton didn't he I don't think he really
thought was me the Bachelorette really
well so you're just kind of out there
doing this thing you know where I was
now that kind of was gonna be a bachelor
so it's a little bit more reserved if
you will and so you know but it didn't
it didn't hurt him so maybe you know if
had I gotten out there but that's just
not who I am you say you thought you're
gonna be the bachelor a lot of people
did including me for a quick Pacific how
close to things come and how did you get
the notice that you wouldn't be did they
explain it what happened I mean there
was no real it so what's pretty cool is
me Jason : I was really good friends and
so we were all very transfer off the
whole thing might be just text each
other like what have you heard what have
you heard which I don't think I've ever
had before so that was kind of cool um
but I mean know he got the call you know
day before and that was it so I you know
his name had leaked if you will so I it
wasn't a blindside you know it really
wasn't I kind of had a feeling that it
wasn't gonna be me there for a little
while so the day before though that's
pretty short wear your bags packed was
that difficult oh no a bachelor packed
or anything like that but yeah I mean it
was weird getting the getting the call
you know and I could just hear the voice
on the way I was like yeah okay funny
but I have to say though disappointing
um to a degree I mean I really do
believe in this process you know I'll
defend it to the last breath um I do
think you can find your person through
that but I don't know you know there's
some good things good things to come
still some fun off duties and doing
things like this would you go on
paradise winter games any of those other
shows uh yeah I think I wouldn't know if
I'm you know if I'm still seeing her
come that time and if I'm in a good
place in my life I definitely consider
paradise absolutely I think paradise is
incredibly successful you know there's a
lot of couples that come out of that and
you still feel ready to get married
yeah I'm still out there looking looking
for my wife absolutely why do you think
Colton was the choice in the end you
know I don't I don't really know what
the producers you know what their
mindset was or what they were really
looking for but I mean I this may not be
a popular opinion but I do think that
Colton is ready to settle down I do and
I think he will find somebody but I
really do think that and I'm actually
excited who decided to vote to watch the
season and they were telling you you're
gonna be the bachelor it's gonna be you
it was a weird feeling numb to a degree
I mean honestly I could have been on any
of three of us
I mean it was I was between I thought it
was between me and Jason but you know
[Music]
[Applause]